لم يقل الرئيس ترامب ما إذا
كان سيحضر
أه حفل تنصيبك أه لكن هل تعتقد
أنه من المهم أن يكون هناك
أنت تضحك أم أعتقد
أنه سيكون أه مهم بمعنى واحد فقط
وليس بمعنى شخصي مهم بمعنى
أننا  قادرًا على أن يثبت في نهاية
هذه الفوضى
أنه خلق أن هناك انتقالًا سلميًا
للسلطة
مع وقوف الأطراف المتنافسة
هناك وهي
تتصافح وتتحرك ، أعتقد
أن هذا هو ما يقلقني بشأن
جيك أكثر من التأثير على
السياسة المحلية.  تقلق
بشأن الصورة التي نقدمها إلى
بقية العالم ،
فأنت تعلم أن بقية العالم
نظر إلينا وسمعتني أقول هذا
عدة مرات أعتذر عن
تكرارها
لقد تبعونا ليس فقط لأن
القوة  مثال على قوتنا
ولكن قوة مثالنا وانظر إلى
أين نحن الآن في العالم ،
انظر كيف ينظر إلينا إنهم يتساءلون
يا سيدي أن
هذه الأشياء تحدث في ديكتاتوريات قرن القصدير ،
هذا
ليس هذا  إنها ليست الولايات المتحدة ،
لذلك
أعتقد أن بروتوكول نقل السلطة
مهم ،
لكنه قراره تمامًا وليس
له أي عواقب شخصية بالنسبة لي ،
لكنني أعتقد أنه من
أجل البلد